Three Muslim individuals in Texas are
facing felony hate crime charges after
spray painting F Israel across the walls
of a church that had been displaying an
Israeli flag.
One of the vandals, Afsheen Khan, is
crying victim. It is a case that is
placing our First Amendment rights and
our sense of justice on trial. The
Council on American Islamic Relations or
CAIR is demanding that prosecutors drop
the hate crime enhancements. CAIR's
Texas branch argues that while the
graffiti was wrong, it constituted
political expression, not religious
hate, and therefore falls under First
Amendment protections.
Here, attorney Allison Grinter Allen,
defense attorney for one of the vandals,
Wernoek Alam, explaining why her client
had a right to deface private property.
I think that that protest, graffiti,
that sort of thing is the language of
folks who are unheard. And so, and my my
heart went out.
>> Graffiti is the language of the unheard?
Local prosecutors disagree, saying
defacing a place of worship with
anti-Israel language crosses into
targeted intimidation categories. The
church's congregation included Jewish
and Messianic members who regularly
display the flag in solidarity with
Israel.
If CAIR prevails in this case, it could
expand First Amendment protection to
acts of vandalism when they're
politically motivated. If the courts
side with prosecutors, it would further
link anti-Israel rhetoric to religious
hate speech. Very interesting times
we're entering. CAIR has long-running
ties to Hamas-linked groups named in a
2008 federal terror financing case and
has been known to defend extremist
behavior under the guise of civil
rights. This case now puts Texas courts
at the center of a national test. Does
the right to speak include the right to
deface? And who decides when political
expression becomes hate? We're joined
now by the great Robert Spencer, founder
of Jihad Watch and author of the book
Muhammad, A Critical Biography.
Mr. Spencer, uh you are a brave man for
the titles that you've come out with. I
know that you've been the subject of of
a lot of a lot of hate speech yourself.
What do you make of this case?
I think that it's the height of
hypocrisy for the Hamas-linked Council
on American Islamic Relations to be
defending these people because we know,
first thing, that if somebody had
written F Iran on the side of a mosque,
they would be the first people to be
calling for the restrictions on speech
and not saying that graffiti was the
voice of the unheard, but saying that
this is hate speech that has to be
prescribed and outlawed and Islamophobia
programs put in everywhere for everybody
even remotely connected to it. And for
that matter, you know, the idea of hate
speech in itself is manipulative and
subjective, and CAIR very cleverly uses
it to try to silence its opponents and
has done so for years. So, it's the
height of hypocrisy for them to turn
around in this case and now say, "Oh,
we're all about the freedom of speech."
They are the enemies of the freedom of
speech. They have been so for many
decades now, since before 9/11. And so,
it just it's kind of jaw-dropping that
they have the gall, the audacity to take
these stances, but they just know nobody
in the establishment media is ever going
to call them out.
And for that matter, a lot of
politicians are afraid of calling them
out. A lot of people are afraid of
calling them out because uh frankly,
they represent a religion that um is
known to carry out individualized
vendettas against people. And so,
there's a lot of a lot of not just
hypocrisy, but a lot of uh you know,
social pressure that comes with it. I
it seems to me, Robert, that CAIR has
had kind of an up-and-down influx in the
social discourse. So, now it seems like
it's having a big comeback, riding this
wave of anti-Israel sentiment on frankly
both the right and the left in response
to the last 2 years.
Oh, absolutely.
Uh they they it's a tremendous windfall,
but it's all for them, but it's also
something that they've been working for
for a very long time. People wonder, you
know, what is it that's happened that
there's so much anti-Israel sentiment
after October 7th, when there ought to
have been a wave of sentiment in favor
of Israel after the grotesque savage
attack that we saw on that day. And so,
the the fact is that this didn't come
out of nowhere. Groups such as CAIR have
tremendous influence. They have the ear
of the establishment media. They have
the ear, as you noted, of all too many
politicians, people courting their
votes, and so on. And so, they have been
sowing the seed for this, laying the
groundwork for this for years. And now,
what we see is to a tremendous degree
the fruit of their labors.
What do you view as CAIR's most
uh effective asset or strategy today in
America right now?
The Muslim vote, which they have wildly
exaggerated, by the way. They have been
lying and inflating the numbers of
Muslims in the United States for many
years. It was way back, I remember, in
like 2002 or 3, they were saying there
were 8 million Muslims in the United
States. There aren't 8 million Muslims
in the United States even now. But, they
have always inflated those numbers and
courted politicians,
tried to get Muslims and sympathetic
people into positions of interest.
They've been very effective at this. And
now, of course, the Democrat Party is in
their pocket because they want the
Muslim vote. And then, the Republican
Party also thinks, "Well, we need to get
into that. What can we give to the
Muslim community that will bring them to
vote for us?" And actually, the
president had some success with this
back
in the last election. And so, they are
able to wield tremendous influence as a
result of people wanting the votes.
So, in terms of a
political vehicle, we saw the the Muslim
population, for the most part, jumping
on board with the left. And it seems
like with their anti-Israel positions,
they're going to stay there for a little
bit. But, as you say, and I was going to
bring this up, we saw
uh a strange influx of Muslim voters, if
not supporting Trump outright,
definitely abandoning the Democratic
Party. So, that puts the political
landscape in a very awkward position,
doesn't it?
Oh, it's very weird, Chanel, because
think about it. The reason why they
abandoned the Democrats was because they
hate Israel. And they thought that Biden
and Kamala Harris were not tough enough
on Israel. And for some reason, they had
the idea that Trump was going to be more
to their liking. And Trump was saying,
of course, that he wanted to bring about
peace, and they thought they could
manipulate him to bring about a peace
that would be favorable to Hamas and
allow them to continue the jihad against
Israel. Now, we hope that that doesn't
turn out to be the case, but at the same
time, when he says to the Israelis to
stop and not to go into Gaza and finish
the job and to destroy Hamas utterly as
they have said was the goal right from
the beginning, then that does feed into
that perception.
Uh it in terms of the co-opting I see on
the right, you're seeing, you know,
personalities like Tucker Carlson,
Candace Owens, big conservative voices
who once used to be huge Islam critics.
Uh now seem oddly silent when it comes
to anything involving radical Islam. You
rarely see Tucker criticizing Dearborn,
Michigan these days. But, you do hear
him talking about uh pretty much the
stuff that you would hear Dearborn,
Michigan residents saying against
Israel. How do you explain that trend?
What's going on there?
Well, I don't know whether they're You
know, you got to wonder when you have
high-profile people like that, like
Candace and Tucker, who suddenly change
the public positions that they've
defended for years. And you can go back
not too long ago and find clips of them
very strongly defending Israel, being
critical, as you say, of Islam. And now,
yes. They've completely turned around.
You got to wonder, are they bought? Are
they being blackmailed? Are they being
intimidated? Or have they genuinely
changed their minds for some reason?
This is the kind of thing that really
they ought to be coming clean about and
explaining and honestly owning up to the
fact that they have changed their
positions. It's abundantly documented
anyway. And so, it's not as if it's some
sort of a surprise or something that
they can reasonably deny to anybody
who's been paying attention to their
careers. So, I think the their followers
and the American people as a whole have
a right to know what is it that's
exactly going on here. There's a lot of
dark whispering about Cutter and paying
large sums of money and so on, which is
kind of ironic since this is the always
the false claim about Israel that
they're supposedly buying influence in
the United States. Cutter, there's
abundant already abundant evidence that
they really are doing so. They've poured
millions and millions of dollars into
American universities and now we see
what they've bought. All these pro-Hamas
students out demonstrating against
Israel all the time and sometimes being
quite violent about it. And so the same
questions ought to be asked of Tucker,
of Candace Owens and of others like them
and they ought to be willing to answer.
Robert Spencer, a pleasure to have you
on. Thank you so very much for joining
us. We look forward to seeing you again
soon.
Thank you very much. I look forward to
it as well. Coming up, investor James
Fishback has filed a Supreme Court brief
backing Trump's right to fire Fed
Governor Lisa Cook. A case that could
redefine presidential power in really
significant ways. He joins us next.
We'll be right back.
[Music]